what do you think that Cassandra she's a
fox and frat she would be called la
Renard and she would be hunted with only
her cunning to protect her she's a babe
she's a Robo babe in Latin she would be
called baby of majora if she were a
president she'd be Baberaham Lincoln did
you ever find Bugs Bunny attractive when
he'd put on a dress and play a girl
bunny no neither did I it's just asking
I know both of you pretty well suitor at
sudo number one here has done nothing
but pine over you all day trying to
figure out a way to win you back and
when this public opportunity to
literally do that arose he pulled his
[ __ ] together risked life and limb
and faced the odds to get up here and
give it his best shot I'm tired of this
whole thing you're both [ __ ] for
each other now why don't you forget
about this let that happen and do what
you're supposed to I think the audience
would agree with me there
No
don't you let go I love you
I'm not even embarrassed to say I just I
love you it's like why don't we say that
every day why can't we say it more often
I just love you I just want to go the
rooftops and scream I love my best
friend Evan we should go up oh my
Boop you know clinically speaking doing
it doggy style there's just some racy
stuff in the beginning there but you can
speed right through it felt like the
AMPA for you with doing it doggy style I
can just be through stuff excuse me
anyways dog it down you can speed right
through that Park every day I come by
your house I pick you up
we go out we have a few drinks and a few
laughs and it's great you know what the
best part of my day is for about ten
seconds from when I pull up to the curb
when I get to your door because I think
maybe I'll get up there and I'll knock
on the door you won't be there no
goodbyes I know see you later no nothing
just left
dependable one and I've always been the
screwed-up one right dad
Harold ain't so perfect ever that time
in Puerto Rico and we picked up those
two well I guess they were prostitutes
but I don't remember band stops right
there and it continues right here
because I think what my friend Mitch is
trying to say is the true love is blind
swears are glasses whatever we got in
front of us
absolutely health and happiness cheers
everybody
I love you so much funny look I'm not a
talker I'm proud of talking I love
shopping for tuxedos for your wedding
man let's have a good time loosen it up
a little bit I want to take a photo
right give me an action pose you look
ridiculous man what am i spoke an eye
can't believe it give me your best Bond
impression why don't you get off your
board and get on get out to view my
dreams and into my car
are you looking for your pot of gold why
does everything I do sound like a
leprechaun you tell me what's my name
it's BIC BIC Mitchum BIC Mitchum was an
act of desperation I'm BIC Mitchum
hey you put that down and if someone
asks you who said it you tell them BIC
Mitchum said it
what do you mean that there's no more
candy I'm BIC Mitchum and I love candy
what bigger BIC BIC BIC BIC BIC alright
I like it
Doug Harris congratulations allow me to
introduce myself my name is BIC Mitchum
your new best man
you